an Alabama father is now threatening to
sue his son's school after the
six-year-old was almost expelled for
using finger guns while playing cops and
robbers
that's when you put your thumb and index
finger in the shape of a gun right well
the first grader also said bang bang oh
no that was seemingly too realistic for
the school and the boy was hit with a
Class III major infraction under the
threat and intimidation rule according
to the school's handbook incidents under
that rule may include a threat to kill
maim or inflict serious harm with or
without the use of any weapon explosive
firearm Etc joining me now is the boy's
father Jared Belcher and his attorney Mr
Reed Martz uh Jared there are a lot of
things about this that are infuriating
but as a parent it it hit pretty hard
when I saw that your son
was uh required to sign on the bottom of
this infraction form the backward and
you know you see it or the misspelled
last name he's six years old
um that is that even legal under any
under any formulation of of the law in
your state for a minor to sign any
document like that
well for Laura for clarification the the
school district simply asked the young
man to sign to acknowledge receipt
although I agree with you uh we couldn't
reproduce the child's signature as it
were
um for privacy reasons but it it
emphasizes the point of just what an
absurd situation this is when we're
dealing with someone who can barely
write their own name because of their
age and yet they're hit with a class 3
infraction equivalent to arson or bomb
threat gang activity yeah well my my
point stands it's a signature
requirement on an acknowledgment on a
document that is that is recognizing
guilt of some sort I mean that's what it
is I acknowledge that you no no I don't
acknowledge anything as the parent Jared
just that aspect of this infuriates me
I'm a mom of three teenagers they don't
always do the right thing but the idea
that yeah no that would be part of this
give me a break
yeah it infuriated me too and from my
understanding he was actually taking
into the administrator's office and
basically interrogated made to confess
and then sign his name
so out of the presence pretty sure out
of the presence yeah out of the presence
of you his parent correct he was brought
in
I mean a little boy he's not going to
know what this is probably doesn't know
what the word infraction is I mean there
are a lot of adults who probably don't
know what the word of infraction is
Jared he was terrified you know and
rightfully so
so here's what else is under the class
III infraction arson assault bomb
threats burglary drugs explosive
Firearms sexual battery
so again finger guns does that fall
within that group of
infractions
but any reasonable reasonable person
would say no but apparently the
administration chose not to be
reasonable
yeah well this was knocked down to a
class too I mean
insane
yeah read what what are your legal
remedies at this point since it was
knocked down to a class too but the
mindset here is all wrong for your for
for the defending your rights the rights
of your client the mindset of this
school is wrong but is there a civil uh
action possible still given what
happened
well we hope it doesn't come to that
Laura I mean we've given the Board of
Education an opportunity a deadline at
the end of this week to uh
do the right thing to recognize just the
absurdity of this situation of charging
the six-year-old and by the way I found
out over the weekend that this is not an
isolated incident there was another
similar situation last year where it
wasn't reduced that that young man
another six-year-old still has a class 3
infraction for using a water gun
exhibiting a water gun in an
inappropriate time during the school day
yeah this this is what we're dealing
with well and and meanwhile people who
are truly violent violent are often
kicked from school district to school
district as we saw with that you know
horrible situation in Parkland where
someone who had threatened had
threatening behavior was obviously a
problem you know he wasn't ultimately
dealt with in the way he should have
been dealt with which was with the
police
um Jared as a father now you're you
think it's good to stay in the school
keep your child in the school
well here's the thing you know before
this incident we have never had a single
problem with the school district and all
the teachers and all the staff have been
one of Wonder wonderful and my son he
really likes the school
so he would prefer to stay in the school
just hide your fingers the school
district
hide your fingers but then you
then
I made and read uh we're going to keep
monitoring this but this is the fact
that this was even approaching an issue
is disturbing hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else